The joe rogan experience you watch off
of robots and not in this country have
found out. It's a weird
moral thing though, right?
Like would you or would you rather have
them fuck a little robot in their closet
somewhere? You know, first instinct
is always like, oh, that's horrible,
but then you're like,
it's Kinda like giving someone with anger.
She was a punching bag. Maybe it's
not the worst thing. It's like you,
they've got that thing,
whatever it is.
Like how do you get it out on that
little sweet, sweet, beautiful punching.
So fucked up.
That's your list. Your child.
Fuck robots don't punch back.
You want to like meet in the middle
of, you're like, okay, it's legal,
but you can't name it.
Well,
do you think that you
could fuck a real doll?
I mean you definitely could if you had to,
but would that be something
you'd be interested in?
I think I couldn't stop laughing at how
ridiculous this situation or rather just
jerk off and think about
things we had as a sponsor.
A flashlight had a flashlight forever.
It's very utilitarian.
You're not confusing yourself.
Has Ever said that word before describing.
She's the girl of my dreams. I've
never been, I've had it forever.
I've never even thought about it. I
couldn't guess why I would want to use it.
Seems Weird. It's weird. It
feels good though. Does it
way better than jerking off.
Yeah, it does. Really. Engulfs
your whole Dick and you,
you put it in warm water and you
get it to a temperature of a potty
and you like it gets too weird,
surreal.
Somehow or another.
There's is like a portal.
Like this tube is a portal to
another woman, another dementia,
but all you can get at is her vagina
and just hold it. That's it. Feels real.
The name of this dimension
is called awesome.
Do you jerk off with a fleshlight
or do you hold it and fuck it? No,
you jerk off with it jerked me
off with the flashlight. Yeah,
but that was for show.
That was on camera behind the curt green.
This interview. We did this on
the podcast. I swear to God,
he jerked me off with a flashlight
producer. I couldn't get hard.
There was a female comic. Whoa. What's
that about? Is that a fuck real?
That's a real doctor. Real though.
They gave him pretty good man.
They were red head though. It was a
documentary on Netflix about people.
Fucking sex robots really have come far
because there are people who fall in
love with these sex robots and it looks
like the fucking taxi driver Johnny on
the spot from total recall.
It's like this is crazy like
animatronic Chuckie cheese, bass player.
It's kind of get to a point where it can
totally mimic you and he's going to get
to a point where it really is like
blade runner. Is that what they are now?
That's a good one. I thought about
buying a dude one to do Jujitsu with.
I was going to order one
[inaudible] and a seal butthole.
That proportions are perfect
because I have a dog.
This is Bubba dumbing the practice
submissions on, but it's super stiff.
It's like this, but he beat you.
You basically can drill the moves,
but it's not the same as drilling
and on an anatomically correct body.
If you had an an anatomically
correct body to practice on,
you'd get some fucking tight moves.
You can't wait.
Can't wait til the day when you're
announcing for robot fights,
not having to zero interest. There's
nothing at stake if they live or die.
It doesn't matter.
Did the whole thing about fighting is
that there's some horrible gigantic thing
at stake. You can fuck one though. Yeah,
he fuck with him. I watch him fight.
What'd you watch? Two robots.
Fuck. I would, I would,
if there was like some sort of a
program that they were running,
I'd want to see like what the program was.
It wouldn't be a jack material.
Completely be fascinated.
They would probably like talk to each
other and numbers and they would both be
dudes. They would both be, there was one
that they just made a fuck doll. Right.
And this is, this just happened
there. There's videos of it.
The robot started speaking like
a weird code to each other.
These were like fucking like
straight up fuck dolls, skynet, dude.
And they would turn them on and then they
started speaking and would seem like a
code. And people were like,
freaking out about this.
I know what you're talking
about. Yeah. They had these
computers. Could, they were,
they were linked together and they
started communicating to each other in a
language that the coders didn't understand
and um, they shut it off. They're like,
what?
Just simply to unplug that they think,
but I heard that my version of it that I
just said might be the most spectacular
version sounding,
but might not be accurate.
And then what did they
might've gotten is like,
they might've got stuck in like a feedback
loop and just been making jibberish I
heard that too.
So I don't know.
Nothing's confirmed way too
fucking stupid to know who's right.
Let's just hope it's that second
one. The first one, funny story.
I just want sounds like a opening
scene in terminator movie. Yeah,
that's what I mean. But at the same
time that the solution being like,
don't plug that in. And again, man,
I know you're gonna want to
hang right there. Like what,
what the fuck are we going to do?
Like I had a podcast with Sam Harris about
it and he is terrified of AI and he's
far smarter than me. Whenever I talked
to him about shit, I go, oh, okay.
And he's terrified.
Terrified.
That's what freaks me out is when people
way smarter than me are terrified about
it. Like a, what's his name who just
passed away? Elon Musk is terrified.
Stephen Hawkins. Stephen
Hawking. No, no, no. This is
going bad. And then you're like,
shit,
sometimes there's too close to it.
I feel like some people also get too
bogged down to the details when you live
here life very ignorantly. Like I do,
I have no fear of AI technology guy.
So I'll be honest with you, self
driving, Tesla already killed somebody
driving a taxi or whatever.
She did something very reckless.
She walked right into traffic and
she might've been a homeless lady.
She might have been on drugs. They're
not, they're not exactly sure.
I don't think the results of
the autopsy are out yet. But uh,
you've watched the video. She basically
just walks right in front of the car.
Like the car's going down the road.
So a person driving it wouldn't have made
much difference. Maybe. I don't know,
man. I mean, it was, it's a hard to tell
whether or not you'd be able to react.
Well, I guess the technology
is, does it ha, you know, the,
the technology of stopping quick
enough to not hit somebody,
they want to make it safer. Right. That's
the idea. Yeah. But I think it is, right.
I think there's more human error when
you're dealing with people drinking,
smoking weed,
paying attention to their cell phones.
I almost would rather just
trust, you know, even if
there's a few deaths per year,
there's way more death for a year with,
you know,
people being it idiot just laid out the
logic for why the robots are going to
the lady in black. I trust them. I
trust them. It's a black lady, right?
I don't know.
He'll be fine.
There's another video of just stopping
perfectly for a white woman running races,
tests.
It needs to reflect on your skin.
Anything but anything dark in the
Mediterranean. It just fucking run. Joe.
The tassel stops it.
All of
that stops it Persian.